buenas noches lo cierto es que el gran
temor del gobierno es que esta variante
o micro aunque lo que sabemos es
altamente contagioso mucho más que la
delta se convierta en la predominante en
este país y hay mucha alarma porque
están creciendo los casos de contagio de
esta variante casi cada dos o tres días
se están duplicando ya hay casi 600
casos en todo el reino unido- es una
variante que ya se está propagando
dentro de las comunidades y ya no está
relacionada necesariamente con los
viajes internacionales por ello el
gobierno debe actuar rápidamente por el
temor de que la efectividad de las
vacunas esté en peligro por ello como
mencionas a partir de este viernes el
tapabocas será obligatorio en lugares
interiores pero no en los pubs ni en los
restaurantes el primer ministro ha dicho
que este plan es lo responsable para
hacer desde el lunes también será como
lo mencionas obligatorio trabajar desde
la casa y el 15 de diciembre a partir de
esa fecha entonces será necesario acá
está el certificado de vacunas para
poder acceder a lugares masivos
johnson insinúa además que las vacunas
pueden convertirse en obligatorias
mientras ha insistido a la población que
trate de tener su tercera dosis la dosis
de refuerzo lo más rápido posible lo
cierto que estas medidas ya han causado
polémica porque muchas personas dicen en
redes sociales que no pueden ir al
trabajo pero si reunirse en los pubs y
en los restaurantes
louis de cambiamos de tema porque este
anuncio se da en medio de un escándalo
por una presunta fiesta en diciembre de
2020 cuando el país atravesaba fuertes
restricciones que reacciones a y tras la
renuncia de la asesora alegra stratton
este ha sido un día de polémicas el
primer ministro ha aceptado la renuncia
de quien fuera hasta hace muy poco su
voz era alegra trató en una periodista
muy reconocida en este país
luego de esa gran polémica que sigue
creciendo y seguramente no terminará con
la renuncia de stratton por al menos
tres fiestas realizadas entre noviembre
y diciembre de 2020 cuando el país
estaba viviendo uno de los
confinamientos más fuertes y tanto que
las restricciones de las restricciones
evitaban que pudiera existir contacto
entre personas que no vivían en la misma
casa johnson ha pedido disculpas hoy en
el parlamento por un vídeo filtrado por
la prensa en la que estrato ensaya en
una rueda de prensa en town street la
respuesta a cómo salir al paso ante
preguntas de los periodistas por esas
supuestas fiestas sin embargo johnson ha
negado que estas fiestas se hayan
realizado y ha ordenado una
investigación de la que no se conocen
mayores detalles lo cierto es que hoy en
el parlamento se ha cuestionado la
autoridad
moral del primer ministro para adoptar
nuevas medidas cuando lo que se sabe por
información profusa de la prensa incluso
con pruebas es que dentro de sus propias
oficinas en downing street en el centro
de londres se rompieron las reglas lo
cierto es que el vídeo el primer
ministro vive un momento político bien
complejo por el peligro de micrón ha
tenido que imponer nuevas restricciones
pero no hay certeza de si el público las
cumplirá porque la credibilidad del
premier está pasando por aprietos